Esta es un fotografía de Maurice Druon,
secretario honorario perpetuo de L'Academie francaise,
la Academia francesa.
Va espléndidamente vestido con su uniforme de 68.000 dólares,
adecuado al papel de la Academia Francesa
como reguladora
del uso correcto del francés
y conservadora de la lengua.
La Academia francesa tiene dos tareas principales:
compila un diccionario de francés estándar --
están trabajando en su novena edición
que empezaron en 1930 y ya han alcanzado la letra P.
También legislan sobre el uso correcto de la lengua,
como el término adecuado para lo que en francés llaman "email"
que debería ser "courriel".
Dicen que en francés la World Wide Web
debería llamarse
"la toile d'araignee mondiale"- la telaraña global --
recomendaciones que los franceses ignoran alegremente.
Bien, este es un modelo sobre cómo evoluciona el lenguaje
es decir, mediante la legislación de una academia.
Pero cualquiera que observe el lenguaje se da cuenta
que es una presunción bastante tonta,
que el lenguaje, más bien, surge de las mentes humanas cuando interactúan entre ellas.
Y esto se puede observar en el cambio imparable del lenguaje --
en el hecho de que cuando la Academia termine su diccionario
estará claramente desactualizado.
Lo vemos
en la constante aparición de palabras coloquiales y jergas,
en el cambio histórico de las lenguas,
en la variedad de dialectos
y en la formación de nuevas lenguas.
Entonces, el lenguaje no es tanto un creador o un moldeador de la naturaleza humana
sino más bien una ventana a la naturaleza humana.
En un libro en el que estoy trabajando en estos momentos
espero usar el lenguaje para arrojar luz sobre
ciertos aspectos de la naturaleza humana
como los mecanismos cognitivos
con los que los seres humanos conceptualizamos el mundo
y los tipos de relaciones que gobiernan la interacción humana.
Y hablaré un poco sobre cada uno de ellos esta mañana.
Permítanme comenzar con un problema técnico del lenguaje
que me preocupa desde hace un tiempo
y espero que sepan perdonar
mi pasión por los verbos y por cómo se usan.
La cuestión es, ¿qué verbos van en qué construcciones?
El verbo es el esqueleto de la frase
es el marco sobre el cual se montan las otras partes.
Recordemos rápidamente
algo que habrán olvidado hace mucho tiempo.
Un verbo intransitivo como "morir", por ejemplo,
no puede llevar un objeto directo.
Debes decir, "Sam murió", no "Sam murió una muerte".
Un verbo transitivo debe
llevar un objeto directo:
"Sam devoró la pizza". No puedes decir solamente "Sam devoró".
Existen docenas o veintenas de verbos de este tipo
y cada cual da forma a su frase.
En consecuencia, un problema al explicar cómo aprenden los niños el lenguaje,
un problema al enseñar lenguas a adultos para que no cometan errores gramaticales
y un problema al programar computadoras para que usen el lenguaje es
qué verbos van en qué construcciones.
Por ejemplo, la construcción dativa en inglés --
es posible decir, "Dale un muffin (una magdalena) al ratón", el dativo preposicional
o "Dale al ratón un muffin", el dativo de doble objeto;
"Prómetele cualquier cosa a ella", "Prométele a ella cualquier cosa" y así sucesivamente.
Cientos de verbos pueden funcionar de las dos maneras.
Una generalización tentadora para un niño,
para un adulto o para una computadora
es que cualquier verbo que pueda aparecer en la construcción,
"sujeto-verbo-cosa-destinatario"
puede ser expresado también como "sujeto-verbo-destinatario-cosa".
Es algo muy útil,
porque el lenguaje es infinito,
y no puedes repetir como un loro las frases que has escuchado.
Tienes que extraer generalizaciones
para producir y entender nuevas frases.
Este podría ser un ejemplo de cómo hacerlo.
Desafortunadamente, parece haber excepciones particulares.
Es posible decir: "Biff condujo el auto hasta Chicago",
pero no, "Biff condujo Chicago hasta el auto".
Puedes decir, "Sal le da a Jason jaqueca",
pero es un poco raro decir, "Sal le da una jaqueca a Jason".
La solución está en que estas construcciones, a pesar de su apariencia inicial,
no son sinónimas.
Porque cuando aumentas con el microscopio
la cognición humana, ves que hay una sutil diferencia
de significado entre ellas.
Entonces, "Dar X a Y" --
esa construcción corresponde al pensamiento
"Causar que X vaya hasta Y". Mientras que, "Dar a Y X"
corresponde al pensamiento, "causar que Y tenga X"
Así, muchos eventos pueden recibir las dos interpretaciones
es un poco como las clásicas ilusiones ópticas "fondo-figura"
en las que puedes fijarte tanto
en el objeto concreto,
en cuyo caso el espacio de alrededor desaparece de la atención,
como en las caras en un espacio vacío,
en cuyo caso el objeto desaparece de tu percepción.
¿Cómo se reflejan estas interpretaciones en el lenguaje?
Bien, en ambos casos, aquello que se interpreta como la cosa afectada
se expresa mediante el objeto directo:
el sustantivo después del verbo.
Por lo tanto, cuando piensas en un evento como causa de que el muffin vaya a algún lugar,
donde le haces algo al muffin,
dices, "Dale el muffin al ratón".
Cuando lo interpretas como "causar que el ratón tenga algo",
le estás haciendo algo al ratón,
y por ende lo expresas como "Dar al ratón el muffin".
Entonces, qué verbos van en qué construcciones,
el problema inicial con el que empecé,
depende de si el verbo especifica un tipo de movimiento
o un tipo de cambio de posesión.
Dar algo implica ambas cosas: causar que algo cambie de lugar
y causar que alguien tenga algo.
Conducir el auto solamente causa que algo cambie de lugar,
porque Chicago no es algo que pueda poseer cosas.
Solamente los seres humanos pueden poseer cosas.
Y dar jaqueca a alguien es causar que alguien tenga una jaqueca,
pero no es como si sacases la jaqueca de tu cabeza
y la hicieras ir hasta otra persona
y luego planearas metersela en su cabeza.
Puedes ser chillón u odioso
o causar que de alguna manera tengan jaqueca.
Así que, este es
un ejemplo del tipo de cosas que hago en mi trabajo diario.
¿Y por qué le debería importarle a alguien?
Bien, existen algunas conclusiones interesantes, creo,
derivadas de este y de muchos tipos de análisis similares
de cientos de verbos en inglés.
En primer lugar, existe una estructura conceptual compleja
con la que automática e inconscientemente realizamos cómputos
cada vez que producimos o pronunciamos una frase y que gobierna nuestro uso del lenguaje.
Podemos concebirla como el lenguaje del pensamiento o "mentalés".
Parece estar basada en un conjunto prefijado de conceptos
que regulan docenas de construcciones y miles de verbos --
no solo en inglés sino también en todas las demás lenguas --
conceptos fundamentales como el espacio,
el tiempo, la causa o las intenciones humanas --
tales como ¿cuál es el medio y cuál es el fin?
Nos recuerdan el tipo de categorías
que Emmanuel Kant sostenía
que formaban el esquema básico del pensamiento humano
y es interesante que nuestro uso inconsciente del lenguaje
parece reflejar esas categorías kantianas --
no le interesan las cualidades de la percepción
como el color, la textura, el peso y la velocidad,
que prácticamente nunca diferencian
el uso de los verbos en diferentes construcciones.
Una cuestión adicional es que todas las construcciones en inglés
se usan no sólo literalmente
sino de una forma cuasi-metafórica.
Por ejemplo, esta construcción, el dativo,
se usa no sólo para transferir cosas
sino también para la transferencia metafórica de ideas,
como cuando decimos, "Ella contó un cuento al grupo"
o "les contó un cuento";
"Max enseñó español a los estudiantes" o " enseñó a los estudiantes español"
Es exactamente la misma construcción
pero no hay muffins ni ratones. Nada se mueve de ninguna forma.
Esto recuerda al "envase metafórico" de la comunicación,
en el que concebimos las ideas como objetos,
las frases como envases
y la comunicación como un tipo de envío--
al decir que "recogemos" nuestras ideas para "ponerlas en" palabras
y si nuestras palabras no están "vacías" o "huecas"
entonces quizá podremos llevarlas "hasta" un oyente
que pueda "abrir" nuestras palabras para "extraer" su "contenido".
Este tipo de expresiones no son la excepción sino la regla.
Es muy difícil encontrar algún ejemplo de lenguaje abstracto
que no esté basado en alguna metáfora.
Por ejemplo, puedes usar el verbo "ir"
y las preposiciones "a" y "de"
en un sentido espacial literal:
"El mensajero fue de París a Estambul".
También puedes decir "Biff pasó de crítico a estable".
No necesitó ir a ningún sitio. Pudo haber estado en la cama todo el tiempo,
pero es como si su salud fuese un punto en un estado espacial
que conceptualizas como un movimiento.
o, " la reunión fue de 3 a 4"
donde concebimos el tiempo como algo que se despliega sobre una línea
Asimismo, usamos la fuerza para indicar
no sólo la fuerza física
como en "Rose forzó la puerta",
sino también la fuerza interpersonal
como en "Rose forzó a Sadie a marcharse"- no necesariamente tomándola con las manos
sino amenazándola --
o "Rose se obligó a irse",
como si hubiera dos entidades en la cabeza de Rose
luchando en un tira y afloja.
La segunda conclusión es que la habilidad para concebir
un determinado evento de dos formas distintas
como "causar que algo vaya hasta alguien"
y "causar que alguien tenga algo"
creo que es un rasgo fundamental del pensamiento humano
y constituye la base de la mayoría de las discusiones humanas
en las que las personas no discrepan sobre los hechos
sino sobre cómo deben de ser interpretados.
Para dar algunos ejemplos:
"terminar un embarazo" contra "matar a un feto"
"una bola de células" contra "un niño no-nacido"
"invadir Irak" contra "liberar Irak"
"redistribución de la riqueza" contra "confiscación de bienes".
Y creo que la idea más importante de todas
tomaría en serio el hecho
que la mayoría de nuestro vocabulario sobre eventos abstractos
está basado en metáforas concretas.
Concebiría la inteligencia humana
como algo formado por un repertorio de conceptos --
tales como objetos, espacio, tiempo, causa e intención --
que son útiles para una especie social con grandes cantidades de conocimiento,
cuya evolución es fácil de imaginar,
y un proceso de abstracción metafórica
que nos permite limpiar estos conceptos
de su contenido conceptual original --
espacio, tiempo y fuerza--
y aplicarlos a nuevos dominios abstractos,
permitiendo así que nuestra especie evolucionase
desde el uso de piedras, herramientas y animales
hasta la concepetualización de las matemáticas, la física, el derecho
y otros dominios abstractos.
Bien, dije que hablaría sobre dos ventanas a la naturaleza humana:
los mecanismos cognitivos con los que conceptualizamos el mundo,
y ahora voy a hablar un poco sobre los tipos de relaciones
que gobiernan la interacción social humana
de nuevo, tal y como se reflejan en el lenguaje.
Y empezaré con un puzle: el puzle de los actos de habla indirectos.
Estoy seguro que la mayoría de ustedes ha visto la película "Fargo".
Y quizá recuerden la escena en la que
un oficial de policía hace detenerse al secuestrador
le pide que le enseñe su licencia de conductor
y éste saca su billetera
con un billete de 50 dólares sobresaliendo
en una esquina de la billetera.
Y dice: "Estaba pensando
que tal vez podríamos encargarnos de esto aquí en Fargo" --
lo que todo el mundo, incluyendo el público,
interpreta como un soborno encubierto.
Esta clase de discurso indirecto es muy común en la lengua.
Por ejemplo, en las peticiones educadas,
si alguien dice: "Si pudieras pasarme el guacamole,
sería maravilloso",
sabemos exactamente lo que significa,
incluso aunque sea un concepto bastante extraño
cuando lo ponemos en palabras.
(Risas)
"¿Te gustaría subir y ver mis grabados?"
Creo que la mayoría de la gente
entiende la intención que hay detrás.
Y de la misma forma, si alguien dice:
"Tienes una linda tienda. Sería una verdadera pena si algo le sucediera",
(Risas)
entendemos esa frase como una amenaza encubierta
más que como una reflexión sobre posibilidades hipotéticas.
Por lo tanto, el misterio es ¿por qué los sobornos,
las peticiones educadas, los pedidos y las amenazas son a menudo algo encubierto?
Nadie se engaña --
ambas partes saben exactamente lo que el hablante quiere decir
y el hablante sabe que el oyente sabe
que el hablante sabe que el oyente sabe, etcétera, etcétera.
Entonces, ¿qué es lo que pasa?
Creo que la idea principal es que el lenguaje
es una manera de negociar las relaciones
y las relaciones humanas entran dentro de varios tipos.
Existe una influyente clasificación creada por el antropólogo Alan Fiske,
en la que las relaciones pueden ser categorizadas, más o menos,
en comunitarismo, que se basa en el principio
"Lo que es mio es tuyo, lo que es tuyo es mio" --
el tipo de esquemas mentales que funcionan dentro de la familia, por ejemplo--
dominación, cuyo principio es "No te metas conmigo",
reciprocidad: "Tú rascas mi espalda; yo rascaré la tuya"
y sexualidad: en las inmortales palabras de Cole Porter: "Hagámoslo."
Los tipos de relaciones se pueden negociar.
Aunque hay situaciones prototípicas
en las que se puede aplicar uno de estos esquemas mentales,
se pueden desplegar y extender.
Por ejemplo, el comunitarismo se aplica la forma más natural
dentro de la familia o con amigos,
pero se puede usar para intentar transferir
la mentalidad del compartir
a grupos que normalmente no estarían dispuestos a practicarlo,
por ejemplo, en las hermandades, las organizaciones fraternales,
hermandades femeninas, expresiones como "la familia del Hombre",
se intenta que gente que no está emparentada
use el tipo de relación que normalmente sería
la apropiada entre familiares cercanos.
Pero la falta de entendimiento -- cuando una persona asume un tipo de relación
y la otra asume uno diferente -- puede resultar incómoda.
Si te pasas de la raya y te sirves
un langostino del plato de tu jefe,
por ejemplo, sería una situación incómoda.
O si un invitado a cenar después de la comida
saca su billetera y pretende pagarte por la comida,
eso sería bastante incómodo también.
En situaciones menos obvias,
existe aún un tipo de negociación que ocurre a menudo..
En el lugar de trabajo, por ejemplo,
hay a menudo una tensión sobre si un empleado
puede hacerse amigo del jefe
o hablarle a él o de ella
usando su nombre de pila.
Si dos amigos tienen
una transacción recíproca, como la venta de un auto,
es sabido que puede ser una fuente
de tensión o incomodidad
En las citas, el paso
de la amistad al sexo
puede llevar, claramente, a distintas formas de incomodidad,
al igual que el sexo en el lugar de trabajo,
en el que podemos hablar del conflicto entre una
relación de dominación y una sexual como "acoso sexual".
Bien, ¿qué tiene que ver esto con el lenguaje?
El lenguaje, siendo una interacción social,
debe satisfacer dos condiciones.
Debe transportar un contenido concreto --
aquí volvemos a la metáfora del envase.
Quieres expresar el soborno, la orden, la promesa,
el requerimiento y demás --
pero también debes negociar
y mantener el tipo de relación
que tienes con la otra persona.
La solución, pienso, es que usamos el lenguaje en dos niveles:
la forma literal transmite
la relación más segura con el oyente,
mientras que los contenidos ocultos --
la lectura entre líneas que esperamos que realice el oyente--
le permite deducir la interpretación
más relevante en el contexto,
lo que seguramente inicia una relación diferente.
El ejemplo más sencillo de esto está en las peticiones educadas.
Si expresas tu petición como una condición:
"Si abrieras la ventana, sería genial",
aunque el contenido es una orden,
el hecho de que no uses el imperativo
implica que no estás actuando como en una relación de dominación
en la que podrías presuponer la aceptación del otro.
Por otro lado, tú quieres el maldito guacamole
Al expresar eso con una frase del tipo, "Si - entonces"
transmites el mensaje
sin parecer que mandoneas a la otra persona.
Y de una manera de más sutil, creo, esto funciona
en todos los actos de habla encubiertos
que implican un rechazo creíble:
sobornos, amenazas, proposiciones
requerimientos y demás.
Una forma de entender esto es imaginar cómo sería
si el lenguaje solo pudiera ser usado literalmente.
Se puede expresar en términos de una
matriz de recompensas en la teoría de juegos.
Ponte en la posición del
secuestrador que quiere sobornar al policía.
Hay grandes chances
en ambas posibilidades:
la de estar con un policía deshonesto o con uno honesto.
Si no sobornas al policía
obtienes una multa de tránsito --
o, como en el caso de Fargo, algo peor --
dependiendo de si el policía honesto
es honesto o deshonesto:
no arriesgas nada pero no ganas nada.
En ese caso, las consecuencias son bastante graves.
Por otro lado, si intentas sobornarlo
y el policía es deshonesto,
consigues la gran recompensa de irte libre.
Si el policía es honesto, consigues un gran castigo:
te arrestan por soborno.
Por lo tanto es una situación peligrosa.
Por otra parte, con el lenguaje indirecto
si emites un soborno encubierto
el policía deshonesto
podría interpretarlo como un soborno,
y entonces consigues la recompensa de irte libre.
El policía honesto no puede retenerte por soborno
y por ende, obtienes la molestia de la multa de tránsito.
Por lo tanto, tienes lo mejor de los dos mundos.
Y un análisis similar, pienso,
puede aplicarse a la potencial incomodidad
de un requerimiento sexual,
y otros casos en los que un rechazo verosímil es ventajoso.
Pienso que esto confirma
algo que los diplomáticos saben desde hace tiempo--
que la vaguedad del lenguaje,
lejos de ser un error o una imperfección
podría ser, de hecho, un rasgo del lenguaje--
que podemos usar a nuestro favor en las interacciones sociales.
En resumen: el lenguaje es una creación humana colectiva
que refleja la naturaleza humana --
cómo conceptualizamos la realidad,
cómo nos relacionamos --
y al analizar las singularidades y complejidades del lenguaje,
creo que tendremos una ventana a lo que nos hace ser cómo somos.
Muchas gracias
(Aplausos)